men don't really need a woman  they want  a woman women control access to sex men  control access to relationships and then  the question for a woman is what would a  woman need to do back then without the  modern conveniences and court system  what would a woman need to do to keep  a man this is the dance  this is the relationship dance  how does a woman keep a man  because he can go from tp to teepee like  little bear love kindness warmth loyalty  it's an emotional currency men you can  comment below that we value you know  what a woman never did  if she knew that her husband could leave  for the winter and maybe not come back  and she couldn't sue him take all his  stuff  she didn't yell  she wouldn't nag  she wouldn't manipulate for that same  reason the man who provides nothing who  fights for nothing would never find  himself  a mate